The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOSH: OK, so let's turn
the page to storyboarding,
which, for us, no matter
what sort of video
you're doing-- live
action, animation,
or some sort of combination--
is vital to the process.
And here's why.
It allows you, basically,
a lot of freedom
to not have to make any really
high stakes creative decisions
and just be creative
at a very early stage.
You don't have to commit
to any sort of production
at that point.
That's why we do it.
And it's why we
share with clients
before we commit to
doing any animation,
because it's very time
consuming for us to animate.
And we want the
client to know what
we're doing before we commit
to doing any of that really
labor-intensive work.
It serves as a blueprint
for timing and visual flow.
So you can get a sense of
the pacing of the video,
whether or not, as
Elizabeth was saying,
things are going to get
stale at a certain point.
It can help you make those
sorts of creative decisions
without having to commit
a lot of resources.
The storyboard can
reveal where you're
going to need to shoot, what
props you're going to need,
the types of shots
you're going to employ.
All that decision
making gets made
in the storyboarding process.
And another, really
crucial thing
is, so often when we're
doing a storyboard,
we realize that the script
needs to be different.
You write something-- maybe
you have some visual sense when
you're writing a script.
And that's good, because--
and I've done it a lot.
So a lot of times I
am thinking visually.
But I'm not always
thinking visually.
And I'm not-- it's not my
strong suit all the time
when I'm script writing.
So a lot of times, we'll
be in a storyboard meeting.
And we'll say, well, this
line is just sort of dumb.
Why don't we say this so
that we can show this?
So that integration of
visual and oral-- the voice--
is a really crucial
part of storyboarding.
So that's why we storyboard.
And let me just
show you an example
of one of our storyboards.
There are many different
ways to storyboard.
But I'll just show
you one example.
The first is--
well, I'll show you
the storyboard for this video
we did for NASA, actually.
And it was produced
by WNET in New York.
And they asked us to
create a series of videos
about different physics topics.
And this one is on
centripetal force.
So I'll just switch
over to-- let's see,
episode-- So this
is essentially--
this is our storyboard method.
We do an Excel spreadsheet
with three columns--
shot, narrator, and notes.
Very simple-- email me, and
I'll send you this storyboard.
And you can use it in
your own work if you want.
Imagine you've
got a tennis ball.
So we start the shot
on the tennis ball.
We either pull back--
we'll watch the video.
I can't remember if
the camera pulls back
or we jump cut or something--
attached to a piece of string.
And we pull back further.
And you start swinging it.
And then-- when did we
have this idea for the dog?
I mean, probably this came
in the storyboard meeting.
Like, OK, we'll have this nice
dog element to the experience.
In circles-- and so
gradually, the camera's
getting further back.
And now we can see
the background.
"Whoa now, watch
out for your buddy."
This is not for
adults, by the way.
I'm sorry.
I should've mentioned that.
This is for, like, elementary
and middle schoolers.
So if you find this a
little facile and dumb,
just imagine you're
13 years old.
"Watch out for your buddy."
So the guy on the
skateboard ducks down.
And then he goes past and waves.
Let's take-- so we start
with-- my attitude about this,
in a lot of cases, is
to start with action.
Like, start with something
that's really compelling.
Like, some-- you don't
have to start, right away,
explaining things.
Just sort of start with
imagining something or doing
something.
There's that old
comment, I think--
this is Hemingway said this, he
talked about "in medias res."
Start in the middle of things.
So don't start with
elaborate explanations.
Just start in the
middle of the action.
So something needs
to be happening
at the beginning of a video.
So that's why we
chose to start--
you got this ball spinning.
There's something going on.
There's this dog.
There's the kid
skateboarding by.
You're starting
with a high level
of engagement and interest.
Let's take a closer look
at the fascinating physics
of this simple action.
And then we go into the
more detailed analysis
of what's really going on.
We talk about f equals
ma-- Newton's second law--
and how it relates
to objects moving.
So I'm not going to show
you the whole storyboard.
But you start to get a sense of
how we put this thing together
visually in a very methodical
way before we did any work-- I
mean, this is work-- but
before we did any animation
or illustration.
And I think John did all
the artwork for this.
And it's very basic.
She's basically a stick figure.
John makes really
nice stick figures.
So he has that talent.
So let me just
show you the video.
And it came out of that process.
Hold on a second.
There we go.
Whoops, that's
not the right one.
Here we go.
This is a minute and 46.
So our challenge was
to do these topics
in about a minute and a half,
a minute and 45 seconds.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Imagine you've got a
tennis ball attached
to a piece of string.
And you start swinging
it in circles.
Whoa, now!
Watch out for your buddy!
Let's take a closer look
at the fascinating physics
of this simple action.
You've probably heard of
Newton's second law of motion
as it relates to objects
moving in a straight line.
Turns out, Newton's
second law also
tells us about the
net force on an object
as it moves in a circle.
When an object
moves in a circle,
its velocity changes direction.
Since the velocity's
changing, that
means we have an acceleration.
And we know from
Newton's second law
that if we have an acceleration,
we have a net force.
Now back to our spinning ball.
For objects undergoing
circular motion,
the net force on the object is
called the "centripetal force."
It's a weird sounding word,
but it's Latin for the phrase
"center-seeking."
It's named centripetal because
the centripetal force always
points to the center
of the circle.
The ball has a
tangential velocity.
So if you suddenly
cut the string,
it would fly off in whatever
the tangential direction was
at the moment you made the cut.
But assuming you
don't cut the string,
and you keep swinging the ball,
the ball's tangential velocity
is constantly
changing directions.
This means the ball
is accelerating.
And the reason it's
accelerating is
due to the centripetal force.
The centripetal force
acting on the ball
is constantly directing
the ball towards the center
of the circle, your hand.
This, combined with
the ball's velocity,
keeps the ball
swinging in a circle.
The same centripetal force that
keeps the tennis ball swinging
in a circle also keeps
roller coasters on the track
as they go through
a loop-de-loop.
So the next time you're having
a blast on a roller coaster,
you can thank the
centripetal force.
[END PLAYBACK]
JOSH: OK, so that's a
pretty short little ditty.
But you can-- I just wanted
to show you how we built it.
And this next thing is-- I'm not
going to show the whole thing.
But it's interesting.
This is a video, a sort
of an insider look at how
Pixar does their storyboarding.
And I'll just play
a little bit of it.
And then perhaps you can
watch the whole thing
on your own time.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-All right, so this section
is the storyboarding process.
And this is where, instead
of writing with words,
we write with drawings.
And we put them on
little pieces of paper.
And it's sort of seeing the
movie in comic book form.
And we'll do a section
of the movie at a time
and we'll pin them
all up on boards.
And then, when we get
a certain chunk done,
we'll show them
to the directors.
Or they will show them to us.
And, I don't know, it's kind of
complicated thing to explain--
-Well, you know, that was
a really good description
of about how better
to describe--
-Something better than that.
-Yeah.
-Well, we could show it.
-Yeah, let's show it.
-With storyboards.
OK, this is the
storyboarding process,
as illustrated by Joe
Ranft, our head of story.
-Yes, so there's the
little, cute, Mr. Storyboard
Artist working very diligently
and happily in January.
-And he has a deadline.
He's working hard
to do his sequence.
Every time he does a drawing,
he pins it up on the board.
And there, he stands back when
he gets done with his sequence.
And he says, hmmm, did
I do it the best way?
And storyboarding
actually balances, like,
composition, cutting, staging,
acting, writing, everything
that goes through the storyboard
artist's mind as he's doing it.
-So he'll try another pass at
it a couple more times until he
feels he's got it just right.
-Just right.
-It's perfect.
-So he calls in the
story department--
-And the directors.
- --and, of course,
the director.
-There you can
see John Lasseter.
Looks just like him.
-Yeah, it does, doesn't it?
Thanks, Joe.
-And then Joe-- or whoever's
pitching, the little storyboard
artist, in this case--
will pitch the sequence.
And in the middle of the
pitch, John gets an idea.
-We all get ideas.
And that's one of the great
things about storyboarding here
at Pixar is it is a free-for-all
once we get in this.
And everybody is out,
coming up with ideas
to make the sequence better,
to make the film better.
And when the pitch
session is done,
inevitably there
is lots of ideas
to make the sequence better.
The storyboard artist
kind of wakes up from it.
-Right, and we're infamous
for putting all our notes
on little post-its.
-Yeah.
-That's why you see all the
little yellow squares there.
And so we'll all leave,
all excited about
the great new ideas we've got.
And then the storyboard artist--
-Mr. Storyboard Artist goes
back and thinks about it
and starts over with all
his notes that he has to do.
Joe Ranft often calls it--
the storyboarding process--
not storyboarding,
but "story-reboarding"
because we work on it,
redo it, redo it, redo it,
to make each sequence, to make
the entire film as best as we
possibly can be.
In the next section,
you're going
to see Joe Ranft, our head of
story on A Bug's Life pitching
to Co-director Andrew Stanton.
-Me.
-And I think Bob's
in there, too.
-I think Bob Peterson,
one of our story guys.
-He's pitching the circus
sequence from A Bug's Life.
Enjoy.
-OK, so Slim and Francis
are hit by the spotlight.
They're not too excited.
And Slim says, tra la la la
la, spring is in the air.
And I'm a flower with
nothing interesting to say.
And then they go,
ah, look, a bee.
And then Heimlich
comes running forward,
I am a cute, little bumblebee.
Here I come!
I want to catch up
with your flowers!
-Oh, oh, oh, I've
got it, I've got it.
What if, like, he
just can't catch up?
He's like-- it's just so
heavy, it's just hard for him
to catch up to Slim.
-Slow down, slow down!
So he's like--
[PANTING]
you flowers, slow
down, slow down!
-Right, right.
-Yeah, right.
That would be great.
You flowers are too fast!
You're running too fast.
Slow down, you guys!
-That's great.
-OK, that'd be good.
-OK, so then he's
chasing after them
and Heimlich runs by the stands.
And there's a little
kid eating candy corn.
And he stops.
And he turns around and he
goes, oh, candy corn, here!
I, oh-- you have
to let me eat it!
Oh!
And his stomach is grumbling.
And he can go, let me help you,
let me help you to finish it!
-Wait a minute.
Is a candy corn funny?
-We were thinking of red vines.
-Would red vines be funny?
That's a little bit
tough for a fly to hold.
-There's those little
sombrero jujubes.
Those are kind of funny.
-The question is, what would a
fly like as far as candy goes?
-Well, dots.
But we already
have a character--
-Candy corn is pretty funny,
though, because it's really,
like-- it's a big triangle.
I think that actually--
-OK.
Yeah, that's why--
-More identifiable.
-I think we should
go with candy corns.
Like, is it too Halloween?
-Nah.
-No, OK.
So he goes, Oh,
candy corn, here.
Let help you to finish it.
-Great.
That's great.
-Tra la la la la.
Spring is in the air.
And I am a flower with
nothing interesting to say.
-Ah!
-A bee!
-I am a cute little bumblebee!
-Ah!
-Here I come!
-Slow down, you flowers!
Oh!
Candy corn!
Here, let me help
you to finish it!
[END PLAYBACK]
JOSH: So they obviously--
they went with the candy corn.
ELIZABETH: Before you move on--
JOSH: Go ahead.
ELIZABETH: --share
the storyboard
that came from Science Out Loud?
JOSH: Oh sure, yeah.
ELIZABETH: Sorry, I totally
forgot that I had this.
JOSH: OK.
ELIZABETH: Not to--
JOSH: No problem.
ELIZABETH: Sorry, Josh.
JOSH: No problem, here.
ELIZABETH: Thanks.
We've been seeing all these
very gorgeous storyboards.
Like, even-- you guys
talk about how it's not
when the real work starts.
But obviously that takes
a lot of time and talent.
So this was a
storyboard that Ashley
did for our very first episode
of Science Out Loud, just
to show you how basic it can
be and still be effective.
So she did an episode
on exoplanets.
Ashley's K-12 video-- ooh!
And what we discovered after
she storyboarded this--
she's talking about a very
abstract, cosmic topic.
So obviously we
can't go into space,
which made deciding what
the visuals were going
to be surprisingly
difficult. Or maybe it
should have been unsurprising.
But we were newbs at the time.
So it was hard.
But she-- literally just
drawing stick figures,
aligning them with her text.
And when we were looking at the
storyboard, we were like, wow.
There's not really a whole lot
going on, except for her just
standing there.
And basically half
of the video was
going to be an animation
without her on screen.
And there would have been no
way for us to really anticipate
the extent to which she was
missing from screen until she
storyboarded this out for us.
And so she tweaked
not only her visuals,
but she ended up
tweaking her script a lot
after she did this to make room
for scenes in which she could
be more present, where it could
be more than a fully animated
video.
But in case you wanted
to see, we actually
kept the first six frames pretty
similar to her original plan.
And we just tried to alter
the animations to make
it a little more engaging.
So I'll show you the
first part of her video.
[AUDIO  PLAYBACK]
-This rock can absorb--
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
So this was-- this
animation was actually
done by our first editor.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-25 years ago, most
people would have told you
that there are only nine
planets in the universe.
Since then, we've lost one.
Sorry, Pluto.
But we've discovered
thousands of others.
So what happened?
Did astronomers suddenly get
a new pair of glasses and now
we're meeting all of
our new neighbors?
Well, no.
It turns that we could've seen
these exoplanets all along.
But we only recently figured out
exactly where and how to look.
We call these new
planets exoplanets, or--
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH: So,
because we knew what
she wanted to do with the
animations ahead of time
because of her story board,
that allowed us to direct her
while we were shooting
to put her hands down,
to look up at the ceiling,
and all that stuff.
And I'll show you one
more storyboard that was
done a little bit differently.
And then I'll let
Josh talk again.
But Alex actually just did
pictures for some of them.
So he did an episode on how
carbon nanotubes are made.
And he had this sort of
"imagine a blank" opening.
And so he just took pictures
of the locations and types
of places that he wanted to go.
And then, from there,
he literally just
drew stick figures.
So you don't have to draw
anything crazy beautiful--
no offense to Alex.
But this was
actually very helpful
for us as well to see how
the pacing of his demos
were going to go.
So we altered his script
again after he made this,
because we realized that it
was a lot of just him sitting
at a table demoing things.
And we decided that
there needed to be
something a little more visually
engaging besides him just
at a table.
But he's talking about
how a thread made out
of carbon nanotubes could
lift up something as heavy
as an elephant.
We quickly realized that we
wouldn't have footage for that.
But this is again,
really basic-- nothing
too crazy-- but helped us a lot
in the planning of the video.
So I'll show you the
first couple bits of his.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Imagine a material
that would let
you use your phone for
weeks without a charge
or would let you build
an elevator to space.
These elevators and
batteries can one day
exist with a material
called "carbon nanotubes."
Carbon nanotubes are tiny.
Take this human
hair, for example.
You need 10,000 carbon
nanotubes to make a rope
as big as this hair.
Despite being small,
they're really strong.
This cotton string holds
up this lego car fine.
But if it was made
from carbon nanotubes,
it could hold up a real car.
[END PLAYBACK]
So originally he
was going to talk
about this model
of carbon nanotubes
at the very beginning
of the video.
But after we saw
the storyboard, we
thought that we should wait
until later on to explain it
and just hit them with
this example first.
So I just wanted
to show you guys
that so you knew that your
storyboards don't have to be
anything super complicated.
JOSH: Cool, thanks.
OK, let's see.
All right, so just some--
we're almost done with this,
by the way.
But some quick tips for
storyboarding-- and I
guess this was something that
Elizabeth was just saying.
It doesn't have to
be a work of art.
Stick figures work.
Focus on details that matter.
We don't draw a
lot of backgrounds.
We just draw the bare
minimum of elements
that will get across the
intention of the scene
or the shot, rather.
It should include a
composition and camera angles.
Is this a wide shot?
Is it a close-up?
What is the cam--
you might make a note
about what the camera's doing.
Is it pulling back?
Is it on a dolly?
Is it tracking something?
ELIZABETH: And just so you guys
know, since we haven't really
talked about that stuff
yet, that's a lot of stuff
that Chris is going to
talk about tomorrow.
So I would suggest that you
try to keep that stuff in mind
and then maybe revisit it again
after Chris talks about it
tomorrow, too.
JOSH: Yeah.
ELIZABETH: And you can also
ask him while he's here, too.
JOSH: Right.
AUDIENCE: You know
I'm not supposed to--
ELIZABETH: It's OK if you have,
like, spoilers in the class--
JOSH: Yeah.
And Chris-- I mean, Chris
knows the grammar of this stuff
better than I do.
Admittedly, I didn't
go to film school.
So we use terms of
art in our studio that
probably aren't appropriate.
But the camera's
close-up on this guy.
The camera's far
back from this guy.
The camera's moving
while this guy's talking.
That sort of--
any of that stuff.
Don't be constrained by--
AUDIENCE: Too many
technical terms.
JOSH: Right.
AUDIENCE: What about aspect
ratio of, like, the paper
that you're using in the
shot that you're gonna use.
Eight and a half by 11
turned sideways, like--
JOSH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or is there another
shortcut that's helpful?
JOSH: Yeah, well a note card
is a very-- turned sideways
is perfect, is a good
16 by 9 approximation.
The template that I'm going to
give you guys is widescreen.
But yeah, definitely
have to think
about those sorts of things.
You don't want to be
doing it in a 4 by 3 box.
You want to think
about the full frame.
And this is sort of stupid.
I don't why I put this.
Make them easy to read
visually and understand.
So I think one thing I
wanted to really stress
is that, for us-- and I
think, for most people,
as you saw on the Pixar
video-- storyboarding
is a collaborative process.
So you can't--
this is a process.
This kind of art
is something that
comes out of a lot of different
minds working together
creatively.
And so the story-- one reason to
make the storyboard really easy
to understand is
that somebody else
is going to have to
use it and work on it.
It's not just what's
inside your head.
This is a part of a process
that collaborators are all
working on.
So it has to communicate
very effectively.
ELIZABETH: And I haven't
mentioned this formally yet,
but obviously, if you're going
to be hosting your video,
you can't simultaneously
be shooting it as well.
So the way that's going to work
is we'll partner you guys up,
or we'll figure something out
to where basically, you'll be
shooting someone else's video.
And someone else will
be shooting yours.
And the storyboard is going
to be really important
for that reason, because
you have to somehow give
the instructions to
whoever's shooting for you
exactly how you
want things framed,
how you want your shot to look
like and things like that.
So I agree completely.
It's a very collaborative
and necessary thing.
JOSH: Yeah.
If there's time,
make a few boards.
Like, a lot of times
people in our office
will make some boards
independently of each other.
And then we'll bring
them all together
and see what we've all got.
Sometimes that's
part of our workflow.
If you have time,
storyboard the same script
in a couple of different ways.
You might get different ideas
with different perspectives.
And as I said before,
revise the script as needed.
Sometimes a great visual
idea doesn't line up
with the script.
Focus on visual story, not
adherence to your script.
So if you come up with a
cool idea, and you may--
you know this is hard
to-- I can say this.
But you just have to experience
it to really understand it.
You might come up
with a cool idea,
but the script doesn't quite
match what you're saying.
So don't feel like you're
locked into that script.
And finally, the
storyboard is only a guide.
Changes are often made in the
production and editing process.
So all this stuff
is very plastic.
You're moving it.
You're changing it as you go.
All right, so how to
make a storyboard.
We brought some paper templates.
You can use note cards,
We don't use note cards.
But it's actually
an interesting idea,
which is that-- then, if you
put one scene or one shot
on each card, you can start
moving the cards around
on the wall, which
might be interesting,
an interesting way to do it.
And each frame should
include the script line
and basic direction notes.
We don't always do that.
But we, at minimum, we
include the script line that's
coordinated with the shot.
So let's workshop.
And there's a couple
different ways we can do this.
Well, first let me go over
what I think this basic format.
John and I will sit up here
and storyboard a script.
And what that script is, I want
to talk to you about a minute.
And then, once we've done
some of it-- maybe over 30
or 45 minutes-- we'll
break you into small groups
and you'll continue the same
script, storyboarding it.
You'll do a few-- some
frames on your own.
We'll walk around and help you.
And then you guys will
present what you have.
And we'll just and
share and discuss them.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Josh, how do
you feel about using
PowerPoint for storyboarding?
JOSH: That works.
That would work great.
AUDIENCE: In my brain, that
would be a better tool--
JOSH: Yeah, sure.
ELIZABETH: That's
what Ashley did.
She made hers on PowerPoint.
JOSH: Yeah, that would work
great-- Keynote, PowerPoint,
that would be great.
And you don't have to
use these paper sheets.
But unless you have
a Wacom with you,
it can be difficult to
draw on your computer.
So the script that we're
going to storyboard,
we can either do a
script that we've already
done-- that we've already
written and storyboarded
and produced.
But it would be-- it would
be wonderful to storyboard it
again with all of your input.
Or we can take one script
that you guys are currently
working on and just get
started on it with you.
So either someone-- is-- someone
is either a victim or very
lucky or some combination
of the two in this.
Who votes for storyboarding
one of our scripts?
OK, who votes-- OK, so fine.
So it sounds like you want to
storyboard one of your scripts.
ELIZABETH: They might not raise
their hand for that, either.
We've got a quiet crew.
JOSH: All right, who
wants to storyboard
one of their scripts?
Oh, come on, guys.
This is absurd.
ELIZABETH: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I find
mine is trivial,
but the one I showed you
yesterday-- is that--
ELIZABETH: Oh, you
mean the hotel one.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because
it's shot there.
ELIZABETH: Yeah, do
you have-- should
we just storyboard
the latest script
that you uploaded to the Tumblr?
AUDIENCE: It's the one
I showed you yesterday.
ELIZABETH: So he's got an
idea that he hasn't fully
scripted yet.
JOSH: Oh, OK.
Yeah.
ELIZABETH: It might
be easier if we have
actual, like, text to a line.
JOSH: Yeah, we need
a script for sure.
ELIZABETH: Just for
logistical purposes.
Does anyone have-- it's not
going to be your entire script.
It's just going to be a portion,
a couple scenes from it.
Does anyone feel comfortable?
And it's OK if you end up
changing it completely, too.
AUDIENCE: Could we do enough of
one that you've already done?
Because if mine has to
be-- I'm just thinking,
from a learning perspective,
that it might be really
interesting also to match
that with--what you are--
actually ended up doing?
JOSH: Yeah, and I
thought that, too.
That was kind of what
we were planning to do.
But I didn't want to
make it all about us.
But if you think it's
instructive, then--
AUDIENCE: I think that
might be nice to have
that framework for everyone,
since everyone else is copying
off of it as well.
JOSH: OK, cool.
So I do have a script here.
AUDIENCE: Do you guys
all have pencils?
Or should I grab some--
ELIZABETH: Do you want
them to do pen or pencil?
JOSH: It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Pencil's nice because
you can erase it.
Yeah, so I think what
we'll do is we'll
start off with John working.
And then we'll all chime in.
And then you can
see how John works.
And then you can do it yourself.
Does that make sense?
Yourselves.
I have the script, actually.
So you can see what
I was hoping we do.
This is a video, another
one of those WNET episodes
on mass and force.
I hope I printed
out enough of these.
I may not have.
ELIZABETH: We can share.
JOSH: OK.
Some people are going to
have to share, unfortunately.
OK, so John-- we use
Flash a lot, just
for illustration and
for storyboarding
and for some
animation components.
I won't go into all that.
But what John has here
is a Wacom tablet.
And it allows us to just get
our ideas in the computer,
basically.
So I need the script.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, let me help.
We can share this one.
JOSH: All right, so let's just
focus on the first paragraph.
And in order for this work,
please chime in and participate
in this process because
what'll end up happening
is we'll end up with exactly
the same thing we already did.
And I don't want to do that.
"Mass is a measure of
an object's ability
to resist being
accelerated by force.
That means the more
massive an object is,
the harder it is to make
it move if it's at rest
or to stop it if it's moving."
So thinking about
the need to make
the beginning of the
video very interesting
and to immediately
engage the viewer,
how do we want to
start this one?
AUDIENCE: Maybe somebody
being pulled by a force
and they're trying
really hard to resist?
JOSH: OK.
"Mass is a measure
of an object."
So we've got an object.
What kind of object do we want?
AUDIENCE: Well, a fat man--
JOSH: Huh?
AUDIENCE: A fat man.
JOSH: A fat man.
Something big.
Something iconic.
Something that really
symbolizes mass.
AUDIENCE: A building, a
monument or something?
JOSH: A building, a monument.
How about-- what were
you gonna say, Josh?
AUDIENCE: I was
thinking of just the
but in some kind of like
stone, like a big stone that
says "mass."
JOSH: OK, that could work.
AUDIENCE: And it falls
down in the dust.
JOSH: OK.
AUDIENCE: A brass weight.
JOSH: A brass weight, yeah.
AUDIENCE: An anvil?
JOSH: An anvil-- those
are iconic things, yeah.
AUDIENCE: A one-ton thing that
gets dropped on someone's head.
JOSH: Yeah, that would be the
Looney Tunes approach for sure.
It OK, so what do
you think, John?
Should we go with
something big that falls?
Is a good-- do we need the
word "mass" on the screen?
AUDIENCE: Not really.
JOSH: OK.
AUDIENCE: Something
big that falls.
AUDIENCE: Stick with beer.
JOHN: So beer could work.
JOSH: Why don't we do the--
let's go with-- let's try
out this idea of the word
"mass" being made out of stone.
That's kind of interesting.
It falls and, like,
crumbles, like,
creates this sort of
cloud of dust and stuff.
That sounds good.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
JOSH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How many is
number of storyboards
do you need for every
one of your ideas?
Like, to what detail
do we need to go?
JOSH: Yeah, that's
a good question.
What you think about that, John?
JOHN: I think that's up to you.
I mean, I'm a very
visual person.
So for me, I'd like to draw
maybe three or four frames
of this mass dropping down.
But for you, maybe you
could just make one drawing.
And next to the storyboard,
explain the action.
Explain what's going on.
JOSH: Yeah.
A lot of times, we draw a red
arrows to indicate movement.
So you could draw
the word "mass"
at the bottom of the
screen with the clouds
and have a red
arrow facing down.
ELIZABETH: I mean,
there's no right answer.
This is really for your benefit
or the benefit of whoever's
gonna be filming it for you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ELIZABETH: So we definitely
go the more rudimentary route
in general.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ELIZABETH: But whatever would
make you feel most comfortable.
I think a rule of thumb--
like, a bare minimum-- is
that any time you're changing
the scene, like you're changing
the camera angle or you're
changing the location,
you definitely want to do
another board for that.
JOSH: And John is drawing in,
like, just a horizon here.
So you have a
sense of the scene,
just at a very
basic level, where
the background is
going to be and where
the word is going to land.
And I think that's enough
for the first line.
JOHN: And this is just
the beginning, too.
A lot times with
our storyboards,
we'll just draw out our ideas.
And then we'll come to the
end of the whole story board
and take a look at it.
And we'll say, well,
we have this ending.
But it doesn't really
match with the beginning.
So then we go back and maybe
we change the beginning
to more match the end.
We're just getting
all our ideas out.
But you're not locked into this
idea now that we've drawn it.
JOSH: Right, OK.
So, next line-- "That means
the more massive an object is,
the harder it is to
make it move if it's
at rest or to stop
it if it's moving."
And that-- yeah, so what do
you think about that one?
We've got this object that's
fallen onto the screen
and now we're talking about
moving it and stopping it.
AUDIENCE: I think
of a person who's,
like, kind of doing, like,
the old pushing against it.
JOSH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And their
legs are moving,
but they're not going anywhere.
JOSH: I think that's a
natural, very, very iconic way
of doing that.
So we have a character
now who comes in.
And, you know, like
this-- "oh god!"--
is trying to push this thing.
AUDIENCE: I think that, for
the second portion, when
the thing slides and the mass
will come sliding off the guy,
he has to try stop
it by [INAUDIBLE].
So he's, like, pinned
to the wall by the mass.
JOSH: OK.
What if this little
guy tries to push it
and then maybe an elephant comes
on the other side of the word
and pushes it-- and is effective
at pushing it towards him?
And then he has to,
like, go this to get it
to-- he's like, oh my god.
And he can't stop it.
And he gets pushed
off the screen.
Something like
that, would that--
AUDIENCE: How about
the screen tilts?
JOSH: Oh, that's a good idea.
AUDIENCE: I like that, yeah.
JOSH: So then it's-- gravity
is working on the word, then.
That could work.
AUDIENCE: I really
like that idea.
JOSH: Yeah, yeah.
And he tries to
get out of the way.
OK, great.
So that covers the
first paragraph for me.
Are you guys-- do you think
we're-- this is a good start?
So let's start with
the next sentence.
Are you all set?
OK.
"The nifty thing about mass
is that it doesn't necessarily
have to do with size.
Think of a big pile of rocks
and a big pile of feathers.
Both piles are the
same size or volume.
But it would take
a lot more effort
or force to move
the pile of rocks
than it would to move
the pile of feathers.
The reason?
Rocks have more
mass than feathers
because they're more dense."
All right, so how do
we tackle this one?
AUDIENCE: You could,
like, camera this big mass
thing and just [INAUDIBLE]
into a bunch of rocks.
JOSH: OK, cool.
Maybe--
AUDIENCE: I don't
know if you want
to go away from the mass thing,
but if you want to keep it,
then just-- I don't know.
JOSH: That's nice-- I like the
idea of making it cohesive,
like it's all-- it's
all working together.
So maybe the mass
slides down the ramp
and hits something and breaks
apart into a pile of rocks.
So there's a pile of rocks
on one side of the screen.
AUDIENCE: The birds.
JOSH: What's that?
AUDIENCE: And it hits the birds,
and then you get the feathers.
JOSH: Oh, that's a good idea.
That's an interesting idea.
AUDIENCE: And you have a pile
of feathers and a pile of rocks.
JOHN: Oh, so this
character is a bird?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOHN: I like that idea.
AUDIENCE: Right?
Now we've got organically
our rocks and our feathers.
JOSH: Yeah, so--
ELIZABETH: Oh, I have a
clarification question.
So, in the script,
is it that the guy
is running from the mass?
Or should he push back on the
mass when he starts to fall?
Oh, I guess he's doing
it on the first frame.
JOSH: He's pushing against it.
And then it starts--
then things tilt.
And it starts to slide forward.
AUDIENCE: And then
he gives up because--
JOSH: Yeah, but is
somebody suggesting
that this guy's a bird?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOSH: OK, so how are we going
to do this in a kind of fun,
nonviolent way, that
this bird, like--
AUDIENCE: Tell us that
he had feathers, right?
If we're not gonna kill a bird,
like, there's pillows, right?
JOSH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How else could you
get a big pile of feathers?
JOSH: Well, I mean they could
just sort of divinely appear,
like they could just fall
from the top of the screen.
AUDIENCE: Someone
could walk on screen
with a wheelbarrow full of
rock, dump it, and then carry
on a bag of feathers that's
about the same volume.
JOSH: Yeah, yeah.
And let me back up for a
second, because let's think
about this in terms of-- So
this first scene-- obviously,
we're talking about
animation here.
Like, we're not going to
do this live action, right?
But let's imagine that the next
scene-- the second paragraph--
is live action.
So then we're talking about more
of like an idea like you have,
where you have some actual
people moving rocks around.
And you have maybe somebody
dumping out feathers.
Is that what we want to do--
is kind of a combo here?
I know I may be--
AUDIENCE: Well,
maybe bringing it
to [INAUDIBLE] the mass
where it falls into his hand,
crushes it.
And he can see,
maybe it's like he
puts it ont he table
and [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH: Oh, OK, so you're
talking about a nice transition
between-- that could
be interesting.
ELIZABETH: Or you could
do overlay to transition--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
with the overlay.
ELIZABETH: That person in
the middle and the mass
falls down next to him or
her and creates a rock pile.
And then--
JOSH: Yeah, so then we have a--
ELIZABETH: And then feathers
pop up or something.
JOSH: Yeah, so then we have
a host at the-- throughout--
we start with a
host, a talking head.
And then we have the mass
fall down beside him.
You see how this gets
complicated, right?
There's lots of different
ways to do things.
Well, for the sake
of simplicity,
let's continue as
if we're just going
to animate this video, OK?
Is that OK with you, Elizabeth?
ELIZABETH: Oh, absolutely not.
No.
JOSH: OK.
ELIZABETH: Of course
it should be that way.
JOSH: Just so that we-- you guys
get the sense of the process.
But you can already see that
there are so many options.
There's so many different
ways to do things.
OK, so back to our feathers.
"The nifty thing mass is
that it doesn't necessarily
have to do with size."
All right, so
we've got this mass
that's rolled down the hill.
And I like the idea of
hitting something and turning
into a pile of rocks.
Are we going to
go with that idea?
AUDIENCE: And maybe
it goes off a cliff?
JOSH: OK, yeah, it
goes off a cliff.
AUDIENCE: It could
hit a pillow factory.
You could have a--
JOSH: A pillow factory.
[LAUGHTER]
That's funny.
Yeah, that's funny.
All right, so here
we have our cliff.
And this action will cover
the nifty thing about mass.
And then, down in the
valley-- or the canyon--
is the Acme Pillow Company?
ELIZABETH: I've seen this video.
So it's really interesting.
Yeah, it's different, this one.
I really like this one.
JOSH: Pillows 'R' Us?
That's
AUDIENCE: Fun.
JOSH: So we've got to do--
think of a big pile of rocks
and a big pile of feathers.
Boom!
AUDIENCE: So then maybe we cut--
JOSH: Then we cut to a pile of
rocks and a pile of feathers.
So this is a jump
cut to a close-up?
AUDIENCE: Just
imagine these piles.
JOSH: "Both piles are
the same size or volume.
But it would take
a lot more effort--
or force-- to move
the pile of rocks
than it would to move
the pile of feathers."
So maybe our protagonist,
our little guy
who was holding the mass thing,
needs to come back in here.
What should he do now?
AUDIENCE: When [INAUDIBLE]
JOSH: Yeah, we could
do it that way.
When is--
AUDIENCE: Could he
try to clean it up,
with a broom or something?
JOSH: Potentially, yeah.
Yeah.
Or maybe he-- well,
any other ideas?
AUDIENCE: If you want, you could
add this-- you could take away
with, like, a leafblower.
Something that just blows off
and thunders off the screen.
ELIZABETH: Yeah--
AUDIENCE: --blow the rocks.
JOSH: That could work, yeah.
AUDIENCE: By adding
onto that, maybe he
tries to blow the rocks
and nothing happens.
And he kicks it.
And he injures his own toe.
JOSH: Yeah.
So what do we have?
A leaf blower, we have
a cleaning up scenario.
You want to try the leaf blower?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
JOSH: Or anything else?
JOHN: Is there any
way we can connect
this with the beginning?
In the beginning, he's trying
to move this word, "mass."
Is there anything there?
Is he, maybe, the janitor?
And this mass is in his way.
He doesn't like it there.
And then he's trying to
do the same thing here.
He's trying to
clean up this mess.
I don't know, just
spitballing here.
Is there a way we can tie
the two things together
is the question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I was thinking that he's
running-- because he's
running away from the mass.
So he runs along with the mass.
And he crashes and booms.
And he lands in the feathers.
He's like getting away
from the feathers.
This clears the feathers.
Then he tries to get it off.
JOSH: That's interesting.
So it's what does it say here?
"Think of a big pile of rocks
and big pile of feathers.
Both files are the
same size or volume.
But it would take
a lot more effort--
or force-- to move
the pile of rocks
than it would to move
the pile of feathers."
So I think we're
back to a scenario
where we need to have
some sort of-- we need
to show force being exerted.
So "It would take
a lot more effort--
or force-- to move
the pile of rocks."
So what sort of--
how can we show that?
We almost already
showed it in a way.
AUDIENCE: Maybe a
cleaning up crew trying
to move them off the frame?
JOSH: Yeah, or maybe
just our character
trying to push this
pile of rocks again.
It's like, oh man, not again.
I got to push something else.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering if
he should have a backpack,
so he could--
JOSH: What's that?
AUDIENCE: We're heading towards
having a student, right?
JOSH: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So maybe
he's our student.
JOSH: Right, right.
AUDIENCE: And that we
identify with the beginning
as some thing that makes
him obviously a student.
JOSH: He's on his way
to school or something.
And this adventure happens.
AUDIENCE: A kid would
obviously, like--
JOSH: Yeah, yeah.
And the audience is kids.
This is middle schoolers.
So we could add a note
to that first scene,
like, kid with backpack.
So we agree that--
so this kid is
going to try to move
these rocks in some way?
He's trying to push them or
gets his back up against them
and tries to get
them out of the way?
AUDIENCE: I like the idea
of there's a clean-up crew.
So there could be
two different kinds
of [INAUDIBLE] on the right.
Here are the feathers.
Or someone sweeping--
one of them.
And the rocks would be just like
this construction truck-- beep,
beep, beep.
Then he comes in
and picks it up.
JOSH: Yeah.
Does that really show the
notion of differing amounts
of force being required?
AUDIENCE: That's
a good question.
AUDIENCE: Maybe less likely.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOHN: Maybe you use the heavy
machinery to move the rocks.
And then we just move
our little character.
And he can move the feathers.
JOSH: Yeah, that could work.
Like, a big backhoe
has to move the rocks.
But the character
is able to just
either blow on the
feathers or move them out
of the way really easily.
JOHN: Can you see
a little berm here?
JOSH: OK, yeah, that's nice.
That work?
Does that "sell it," as we say?
So we need to show
that the-- do we
need to show the backhoe first?
"It would take a
lot more effort--
or force-- to move
the pile of rocks."
And then we have another
shot-- "than it would
to move the pile of feathers."
We see the rocks gone
in the next scene.
JOHN: Right here they're gone?
JOSH: Yeah.
So he gets through-- so
the feathers are gone.
And then we've got
another line here.
"The reason rocks have
more mass than feathers
because they're more dense."
AUDIENCE: Maybe you could,
like, have a scale with, like,
the backhoe with rocks on it.
And you've got feathers
on it or something.
[INAUDIBLE]
JOSH: Is it-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's why I was,
like, it's not a type of scale.
JOSH: Right, right.
I'm not a scientist-- and you
guys can help me with this--
but does density really
equate to weight?
If we just show them on
a scale, does that really
show that one is more
dense than the other?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I guess not.
AUDIENCE: I mean, it's indirect.
So maybe a better way
would be to address density
more directly?
JOSH: Yeah.
Could we do something,
like-- just very simple,
where we just-- the
character extends two hands.
In one hand is a rock.
And in the other is a feather.
And we just-- and we
put the words more
dense above the hand
with the rock in it
or something like that?
How do you visually say
something is more dense?
Like, how do you
show that visually?
AUDIENCE: The
tractor, or whatever
that heavy machine was, it
could be throwing the rocks off
into the ocean.
And you see the rocks sinking.
And then the feathers are just
floating in the air, maybe just
landing on the surface.
JOSH: That's an
interesting idea.
AUDIENCE: It
definitely shows that.
And I'm not sure how
familiar the kids will
be with the concept of density.
But having the water--
sinking, floating,
maybe-- makes the
point a bit better.
AUDIENCE: You already
introduced volume.
So I feel like to
introduce density
wouldn't really be
doing, like, what
came before, which is volume.
I don't think it
would do it justice.
Because density is
volume and mass.
So if you're able to have volume
and then go to mass after that,
I think that's where
they'd connect,
that the mass could
be different even
though the volume is the same.
And you would still have
different densities.
ELIZABETH: I mean,
the other thing
is that the video isn't
really about density.
The video is about
mass and acceleration.
JOSH: Yeah.
ELIZABETH: So it
may not even be--
and, like, this is sacrilege--
but it may not even
be that important
to really define
what density is in this
particular video, which
is why maybe it's
OK to say one's more
dense than the other.
It's like, a couple
minute video?
JOSH: Yeah.
ELIZABETH: The point
is really about
how things that have more
mass require more force.
If you start going
into density, I'm
afraid that people
would also want
to talk about what the
difference between weight
and mass are, too.
JOSH: Yeah, true.
ELIZABETH: So again, it's
like, at what point are you
branching off too much
from the point of the video
and the main point of the story?
JOSH: That's a good point, yeah.
Well, "The reason rocks
have more mass than feathers
because they're more dense."
Yeah, so maybe--
I don't remember
what we did in the video we
actually ended up producing.
I think I would go with the
hand displaying the two things
and think about how they're
essentially the same size.
But one is very light
and one is this rock.
It's dense.
ELIZABETH: Can you-- is
it possible to zoom in
on the rock?
Because density is really that
there's more stuff per space,
right?
So somehow have the
rock bulge a little bit
to show that frame
is like stuffed
with as much stuff as possible.
JOSH: Yeah.
ELIZABETH: And then
show the feathers
and show like a lot more air and
space in between the feathers.
And you can still put
the label "more dense."
But maybe there'd be some
sort of visual cue associated
with that as well.
JOSH: Yeah, potentially.
This is a toughie.
JOHN: So you're saying,
maybe, we cut to a new shot
where we see a rock and
a feather side by side?
And then maybe we
see like, a view
of each one under a microscope?
ELIZABETH: Almost,
but again, I don't
know if that's distracting
too much from the main point
of the story.
JOSH: Well, I like that
idea-- the microscope image.
Like, we show like the
crystalline structure
of the rock is really, it's like
a lot of stuff packed in there.
AUDIENCE: What if he was poking?
So you can't poke a rock but
maybe he takes out a pencil
and pokes through the feather.
We can do that [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I think
it's too complicated
to go with this concept.
Like, I don't know.
The word "dense," like, I
don't think we have to-- I
don't know if we have to
explain that right now.
JOSH: Yeah, well, let's think
of another strategy here.
How necessary do you think
this line is in the script?
I mean, is it vital to
the script itself, I mean,
to the whole story?
I don't know, I
haven't given you
guys a chance to
read the whole thing.
But maybe this is
one of those moments
where we take this line out.
And we end the paragraph
with moving the feathers.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's far easier.
JOSH: Yeah, it is easier.
And it might be one
of those moments
where this line is a distraction
from the-- I think that's where
we're struggling right now.
JOSH: Yeah, yeah.
So let's say, OK, we're going
to remove this line for now.
And some client is
gonna come to you
and say, well, why did you
guys take that line out?
We really need that.
And then you have
to argue for that.
That's all part of
the process, right?
Like, well, we talked about
this for about an hour.
And we realized that
this wasn't really
important to the process.
You know, and that--
AUDIENCE: How often
do you feel like you
have to, like, you have
an artistic vision of what
direction it should go?
JOSH: It happens all the time.
Yeah,
AUDIENCE: And then
you have to comment?
JOSH: In my
professional opinion--
and that's when I
have to sort of fake
this professional persona--
we don't think you
should have this
line in the script.
And in retrospect, this
line is in the video we--
but we didn't have 15 people
to talk about it with.
We only had four.
ELIZABETH: But do you see how--
like, are people OK with taking
that line out now?
Like, you see why maybe
that's a good choice?
Would you have reacted
that positively
to the idea of taking this out
maybe five days ago, before we
had gone through this class?
Because I feel that
is the reaction
of a lot of scientists.
Like, wait, wait,
wait-- this is accurate,
but it's not precise, like
you were just talking about.
You have to talk about density.
And that's sort
of-- I mean, I want
to tie this back to the work
that you guys are doing now.
You guys see how this
process is really
making you examine
what is truly necessary
and what isn't to the project.
Because this is going to
happen to your scripts, too.
You're gonna sit
down and storyboard.
And you're gonna rack your
brain over one sentence
that you can't think of
an appropriate visual for.
And maybe that's a key for you
to reconsider whether or not
that part is truly vital.
But you are not forced to
do that until you think
about things like
storyboarding and think
about things like an overall
narrative to your video.
Because otherwise you're going
to do what most scientists do.
And I-- I mean, I say this
as a former amateur would.
But the tendency is to just
throw as much information
out there to cover
your grounds, right?
JOSH: Yeah, and I
think-- if I remember
correctly-- this script
was a lot more complicated.
We received a kind of rough
script from the client.
And I had to edit it down
and get it into something
that worked for the medium.
And we had some
discussions about well,
like, why can't we say that?
I mean, exactly what you're
talking about happened.
And I think that this one
just sort of slipped through.
This one got through.
And, in retrospect,
maybe we shouldn't
have produced that line.
But I love that we're
thinking about this.
I think this is a really cool--
this is a really important part
of the process.
AUDIENCE: This goes back
to the core concept.
I mean, the core, number one
thing is know your audience.
Think about your audience.
I was actually
earlier today helping
one of my graduate fellows
apply for the master's
in journalism program here.
And she has to write a 500-word
piece on a science topic.
And she was trying her hardest
to consolidate an experiment.
And she was trying
to think about what
the lay audience cares about.
And it was so hard for her.
And she distilled it down
to two and a half sentences.
But I told her even that was
too much for a New York Times
piece, that no one cares about
which mice were chosen and why
for this experiment.
And then-- that this is the
crux of, like, what I think
is one of the hardest things.
JOSH: Right.
And there was-- I think on
Monday we heard this phrase,
"kill your darlings."
There's that--
AUDIENCE: And that'll
come back [INAUDIBLE].
It's my favorite.
JOSH: Yeah, exactly.
And I think, in
retrospect, introducing
the notion of density into
this is a real distraction.
It's not what this is about.
So yeah, I would
say let's strike
that line-- that we have
the luxury of doing that.
So I want to stop there
with our portion of it.
And then kind of let you
guys break up into groups
and do maybe the
next two paragraphs.
If you make it
further, that's fine.
And then we'll walk around
and to you about your ideas.
But-- so how many
of us are there?
1-2-- there's seven?
ELIZABETH: There are eight.
JOSH: Eight?
OK, so that is nice--
two groups of four.
Yeah, I'll let you divide
up however you want.
If you just want to go with
you four over here and then you
four over here is fine.
You guys from this-- are you
guys, I would say not all three
of you guys together because you
know each other and all that.
But yeah, that's let's
get started with that.
ELIZABETH: And if you guys
need to take a break to go
to the bathroom, this is a
wonderful opportunity to do
that since we're--
JOSH: That's a good idea.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's take a break
before you start.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: --the student
just standing there.
So you could have
a teacher come in.
AUDIENCE: Second teacher--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And I guess they sit
down and it's like--
JOSH: You could actually
use Elizabeth and me.
That would be--
AUDIENCE: -gotten behind a
word that you're like, oh,
that's why we use
that word, right?
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: They sort
of like blow up.
AUDIENCE: There were people--
AUDIENCE: --stuff them
inside their shirt.
And now they're really big.
JOSH: These people
write a press release
about a product that
hasn't been invented yet.
So what do you guys got?
Is this thing on?
Sorry.
Hot mic.
All right.
AUDIENCE: So we've, for
the third paragraph--
what it takes to
show how-- "Picture
a student and a teacher."
So we have a student
and a teacher.
So the student is
like, really happy.
And then the teacher is like--
[MAKING A FROWNING FACE]
Plus he has to do this
exercise with you,
I guess probably
to find [INAUDIBLE]
And then he zooms out.
And you see him there,
sitting on a chair.
So then you show this shot
with him sitting on a chair.
And I haven't drawn
the last one here,
but, it's supposed
to show from, like,
the corner angle where you see
the student being very small.
And then the teacher
will be, like, massive
to show the difference in this.
JOSH: So you do
the classic thing
where you have an above
shot for the student and a--
from the bottom for the teacher.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOSH: And they're
sitting in the chairs.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOSH: OK, cool.
AUDIENCE: I guess that stopped
with the third paragraph.
JOSH: Yeah, I mean
that's enough.
I mean it sounds like you
guys went further than that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we
went further than that.
JOSH: OK, go ahead and share it.
I'd be curious to see.
AUDIENCE: Where are my-- Ah!
So then he-- so he
just pushes him off.
I guess he wants a
little bit of comical--
so you can see from the side.
But because he does rolling
chairs with this and things,
so the kid will go "whee."
Now there's physical distance.
But there's this little
line they put over
to show there's a difference
between [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH: OK, cool.
I like where that's going.
That sounds cool.
Did you guys have any thoughts
or feelings about the process,
like-- does this give
you a sense of what it's
really like to do
this stuff and have
to run these scenarios through
your brain and visualize them?
AUDIENCE: I think,
like, the big thing
we found was you have this
text but, like, knowing
how to read it.
So like, we just-- with
that first student teacher--
we read it like, "picture
a student and teacher."
Like that's just-- if we
have a frame of a student
[INAUDIBLE] a teacher,
that would slow that down.
So we had to be like,
picture a student.
Now picture a teacher.
JOSH: Right, right.
So you're thinking about
directorial sort of things,
like how you're going to--
how the voiceover is going
to change as a result of these
visual decisions you're making.
Yeah, that's cool.
You guys?
It sounded like there was less
of a hum going on over here.
Did you guys-- what do you
have for that third paragraph?
AUDIENCE G: Well,
basically we have
the kid that's standing there
from the last part, you know,
where the feathers
have been swept away.
And the teacher walks up
with two rolling chairs.
JOSH: OK, cool.
AUDIENCE G: They sit down.
There's a poof of smoke.
And that's where it
transitions to live action.
JOSH: OK, I like that.
That's a cool idea.
AUDIENCE H: And the
teacher grows also.
That's how we're
sure she's massive.
JOSH: Oh, the teacher grows.
In live-- How are you
going to grow the teacher?
AUDIENCE H: We stuff
her with pillows.
JOSH: Oh, that's funny.
So, like, maybe a stop action,
where you take a frame.
And then you put one
more pillow in her.
You take another frame.
And you get like-- and
then you do between frames.
And you've got, like,
maybe 30 or 60 frames
of the student-- of this teacher
getting bigger and bigger.
That could be really funny.
Good idea.
Any thoughts about the process?
ELIZABETH: What was
the hardest part?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE H: How to make it
visually engaging, I guess.
So have enough interesting
shots but not too much.
JOSH: Yeah, true.
It's like that fine line, right?
You don't want to overdo it.
You want to-- it
really, really boils
down to this kind of
empathy for the viewer,
for their ability to
understand things.
And maintaining this
balance between your desire
to have them engaged and
their need to understand--
and kind of threading that line.
ELIZABETH: We'll talk about
this a little bit more
during our editing lecture.
And Chris will talk
about it tomorrow.
But visual pacing
is another thing
that storyboarding can show you.
So again, I'm not, like,
balancing between the sides.
If you have so many shots that
are just changing too quickly,
then that can be a very
nauseating experience
for the viewer.
And I'm gonna show you guys a
rough cut of one of the videos
that we made where
that happened.
And it just felt too rapid.
So we slowed it down.
JOSH: OK, yeah, that's
really good point.
Two last really small things.
We didn't get to talk
about After Effects.
But it's essentially
a piece of software
that lets you layer
video and artwork on top
of each other in time.
And I'm sure Elizabeth will
talk a little bit about it.
But if you want to
email me, and you
have a specific thing
you want to animate,
and you want some advice
about how to do it, feel free.
You can come by the studio and
say hey, I've got this problem.
How would I animate this?
We can give you
some tips about how
you would go about doing it.
ELIZABETH: And just so
you guys know, again, you
have free access to Lynda.
But there's a computer lab next
to 26100, the new media center.
And all the Macs are
outfitted with FinalCutPro,
After Effects, the entire
Adobe creative suite.
And you guys have
access to it anytime.
So if you're interested in
playing with that software,
or going on a media
experience, let me know.
AUDIENCE: Is After Effects
different from IS&T?
ELIZABETH: It is if
you're installing it
on a machine at MIT homes.
I can ask about maybe getting
a license for you guys
just for this class.
AUDIENCE: You can also
just sign up on Adobe
and get a month's free trial
of all the Adobe Creative Suite
things.
So you can just sign
up with any email
and download the program suite.
JOSH: And then the
last thing I wanted
to do is to show you the video
that we actually ended up
producing for this script.
So here we go.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Mass a measure of
an object's ability
to resist being
accelerated by a force.
That means the more
massive an object is,
the harder it is to make
it move if it's at rest
or to stop it if it's moving.
The nifty thing about mass
is that doesn't necessarily
have to do with size.
Think of a big pile of rocks
and a big pile of feathers.
Both piles are the
same size, or volume.
But it would take
a lot more effort--
or force-- to move
the pile of rocks
than it would to move
the pile of feathers.
The reason?
Rocks have more
mass than feathers
because they're more dense.
To show how it's harder
to accelerate something
with more mass, picture a
student and a teacher each
sitting at rest in a rolling
chair facing each other.
Let's also say the teacher is
more massive than the student.
When they both push
off each other,
they go rolling backwards.
Notice how the student
goes back much farther
and faster than the teacher.
The teacher accelerates less,
since she is the more massive
of the two objects.
And it takes more
force to accelerate her
than it does the student.
All of this has to do with
Newton's Second Law of Motion--
f equals ma.
It says, for a set acceleration,
an object with more mass
requires more force
to get it moving
at that set acceleration.
As mass increases,
the force required
to accelerate or decelerate
that mass increases as well.
Now don't you feel
massively smarter?
-Mm-hmm.
Whoa!
[END PLAYBACK]
JOSH: All right, so that's
what we ended up doing.
So you can see how
the timing allowed
us to sort of cheat a few
lines, like the density line.
We just sort of let
it play through.
So there's some
moments here where
you're allowing the viewer
to take in what's going on.
There's not constant action
going on, you'll notice.
But the action is
at key moments where
we need to keep things--
This is so abstract.
But again, there are
no right answers.
But there some-- if
you do it long enough,
you'll sort of start to get
a sense of what decisions
to make.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: How long did that
video take start to finish?
Like, from storyboarding.
JOSH: I would say, John, you
can help me remember all this.
But you know, the script was
maybe a couple days, revisions
and so forth.
And then we probably sat
down for at least four
to six hours-- almost a
whole day-- storyboarding it,
every scene.
It was a complex thing.
We're not physicists.
So we had to
understand this stuff.
We had to do some
background research.
About a day
storyboarding, and then
about a total of
three people doing
the animation and illustration.
And that took maybe three weeks.
So I'd say about a month
to do the whole thing.
ELIZABETH: Real quick,
because you guys are going
to stay on for another class?
JOSH: Sure, I can do that.
ELIZABETH: I mean, if you
need to go, that's fine.
JOSH: That's OK.
We can hang out.
JOSH: So thanks guys,
thanks for listening.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSH: Josh gave you
guys all his info.
JOSH: Yeah, feel
free to get in touch.
ELIZABETH: For
today's assignment,
you guys will be
storyboarding one scene
from your script,
which is why it'll
be a good idea to have some
semblance of a script together.
I know that you're still
revising all that stuff, too,
which is why we're only having
you storyboard one scene.
And then tomorrow, Chris will
help you shoot that scene.
So as far as the storyboard
goes, you can use these sheets,
you can use PowerPoint,
you can use note cards.
But just upload them
as images onto Tumblr.
And then all the assignment
details are on the syllabus.
I wanted to mention--
this was something
that I was going to show
you guys during the editing
portion.
But you can actually
storyboard in post-production
after you've shot things.
So this was an episode on snot
that I'd filmed with George.
And basically, after we
got all of the raw footage
from the first
takes, these are sort
of like stills from each
major scene of the video.
There was a portion where I did
a demo of this, like, fake snot
that I made.
But I had filmed it in
Katharina Ribbeck's lab
and the sun had set.
And my delivery was terrible.
I was super tired that night.
So there were a couple
things that jumped out to us
after we watched everything.
One being that I am
lit very dramatically.
And I wanted to have more of
a casual feel to my parts.
And I felt like we
should only dramatically
light Katharina Ribbeck.
The other was that--
I thought, well, how
bad was that decision really?
Like, is it really
worth shooting again?
So we shot it again
because we had the time.
And then it was a
matter of deciding
which set of footage to use.
So what we're doing
right now is we just
put together a cut of the
video using both clips.
But another thing
that you can do
is storyboard the
stills from the footage
that you take day of.
So here I can see
how that scene looks
in the context of
everything else we shot.
So I see that, like, I'm
wearing a lot of blue.
The whole video
looks fairly blue.
I look a lot more like Katharina
Ribbeck in this set of footage
than I do the rest of me, right?
Like the way I'm lit
in all the other scenes
is really different from this.
So that's what the re-shot
footage looks like.
One-- the snot demo
went a lot better
the second time we did it.
My delivery was
also a lot better.
But I'm also lit
a lot more flat.
I actually think
that the footage
that we had before-- it looks
a lot better, like the lighting
is a lot more flattering.
But it's a lot more
formal and traditional.
And it's hard to know
how much that jumps out
in the context of the
rest of your video
until you line up
all these stills
and you sort of
storyboard this way.
So we haven't actually
finished this video.
I'm in the process right now.
Like, this is exactly
where I am with this video.
I thought I would
show it to you today
since we've been talking
about storyboarding
to show how you
can do it not just
in pre-production, but also
after you've shot material.
So we have about 20
minutes left in class.
I thought that it would
be good to give you
guys a chance to get started
on storyboarding your scene
while we're around.
So if you guys have
questions, I'll
be here until the end of
class and a little bit later.
You can ask Josh as
long as he's around.
But does anyone have
any questions right now
about what they
need to do tonight,
about storyboarding, writing?
JOSH: How are your scripts,
like, what shape are they in?
Are you happy with them?
Do they still need more work?
ELIZABETH: Yeah, we can
also talk about scripts
right now, too, because take
advantage of Josh's background
in writing as well.
JOSH: How long are the scripts?
What are you shooting for,
three minutes, two minutes?
ELIZABETH: Like three
to four minutes.
Five is the absolute max.
JOSH: We do 150
words per minute.
I don't know if that's
something you guys have already
talked about.
AUDIENCE: How much is one scene?
So what does that entail?
ELIZABETH: Well, I think of
scenes as sort of locations
almost.
And so let me go back to--
sorry, my lap-- bye, Jamie.
A scene kind of encompasses
a general statement.
So that the way I
broke up the storyboard
is I basically just did
stills of each scene.
You can kind of consider
the whole top row
as, like, a general
scene, one which is
how I originally scripted it.
It was just sort of like
the visual introduction
to the video.
But breaking it up
into scenes is nice,
because then you'll notice if
one scene has a lot of text.
And then you have a scene right
afterwards that's very short.
And you just have a series
of really quick scenes.
Maybe you can think about
restructuring or spreading
out the material
a little bit more.
Because, like I said,
what you don't want
is either really long
shots or really long scenes
where you're not really
changing that much,
or if you're doing too
many, really quick changes.
But I don't know.
I don't have a good definition
for what a scene technically
is.
JOSH: It's kind of a
unit of information.
When I think about writing,
I think about paragraphs.
This is kind of a
discrete unit that's
imparting a certain
part of the narrative.
And that's-- for
me, that's a scene.
ELIZABETH: Yeah.
I think the way I'd scripted
it, those four shots
are all different locations.
But I listed it as scene one.
Like, where you see
Professor Ribbeck
and then I'm right
there in front of her,
I also chunk that
together as one scene.
But then, when we
were editing and sort
of taking note of
all the clips, we
denoted one as like scene
five and then the one
after as scene five
A. But, in general,
like it's the same sort of idea.
We're in her lab
in that portion.
Does anyone have
any other questions?
AUDIENCE: What was, like, the
motivation in using professor
to--
ELIZABETH: So, in
this particular one,
I wanted to highlight
the research that
was going on here.
And I also wanted to get her
involved because I knew her.
And I really like her.
And it was sort of
like a quirky breaking
down the fourth wall moment.
So what happens
in this scene is--
I set it up in the previous
scene as saying snot
is more than just this.
And then it jumps to her.
And she finishes my sentence.
And she goes, it's actually xyz.
And then it cuts
to a wider shot,
revealing that I'm in
front of her, interviewing.
And you see the camera
interviewing her.
And I'm, like--
[GESTURING TOWARDS PROFESSOR]
And then I go, she would know.
And then her name
sort of pops up.
Partially because we wanted
to have her in the video,
but we didn't want it
to be really formal.
Because that shot is a very
traditional formal interview.
So we wanted to make it quirky.
And we also wanted to sort
of like informalize it.
So that's why we
broke out of that.
And I did the whole
like, she would now.
And then we could make that
setup a little more fun.
AUDIENCE: How do you think
about the authority of the host,
right?
Because you can say things
that are easily verifiable.
But then if you're
going to say something
about snot that, like, most
people don't know, then
on whose authority
do you say this?
I've watched like an
Alton Brown thing.
And I was like, all
right, that's wrong.
And like, but you are
talking about all the things
I want to know.
And now I don't know
when you're lying to me.
ELIZABETH: Yeah, well,
I mean, part of it is,
that's the responsibility
that you have as the host,
is that the viewer
has, by default,
placed their trust in you.
I think with us, we're
not going to have as much
of a problem to prove because
everyone knows that all
the hosts are students at MIT.
And in our YouTube
descriptions, we
say that all the scripts
were fact-checked
by postdoc researchers.
For this, I mean, that
was one of the reasons
why we used her is because I
could explain her research.
Or I could just have
her say it, which
I thought was like a cooler
window into the world
here, which is what I was
talking on the first day.
How do you create the
window into the world
that people don't
have access to?
I also studied bioengineering
for my undergrad.
So all the material
for the script
came from the class I took
from Professor Ribbeck.
But I think you don't take the
time in your video to introduce
yourself necessarily.
And maybe you should.
That's always something
we've considered,
is that something that we
need to introduce into Science
Out Loud.
The host saying at the
beginning, like, I'm Jack
and I work at MIT's D-lab.
And that's sort of what we
did with Lindsey's episode
just a tiny bit.
But there are ways of
establishing authority
where you don't have
to vocally do it.
So in Lindsey's episode,
we filmed at MIT is D-lab.
And instead of saying,
like, we're at MIT's D-lab,
we just spent a few seconds
doing shots of the sign that
said D-lab, basically.
If you guys want to see
it, I can show you later.
But I don't have a
good answer for that,
because I think that, even
if you're Stephen Hawking,
people can question
your authority to say
the things you're saying.
And the point of the
video isn't necessarily
to establish that-- or at least
the point of these videos.
Your material should
be accurate, though.
AUDIENCE: You showed us
the next slide, right?
And you have this [INAUDIBLE]?
ELIZABETH: Oh, yeah.
So George made me
wear the goggles,
partially because I think
he was trying to torture me.
But there are some environmental
health safety standards.
And since we were
technically in a lab,
even though I wasn't
working with anything
biohazard related, the lab
itself required goggles.
So that's why I wore gloves
and a lab coat and goggles.
If you guys plan on filming
in any sort of environment
where that might be an
issue, we'll talk about it
more during producing.
But just keep that in mind, too.
We took shots of me with
and without the goggles,
just in case.
Any other questions?
OK, so I'll let you guys work.
And we'll just sort
of circulate through
and see if you need any help.
But again, I just
wanted to give you
some time to make the most
of the resources here.